very thorough one but um uh as a baptist growing
up is there any more after that this is the last
one right that's the last one that came in late
that's not on the paper okay let's let's long
questions don't usually have good answers but go
ahead as a baptist growing up i was taught that if
we try to keep the sabbath in the ten commandments
then by galatians 5 3 are we obligated to keep
the entire law perfectly since we cannot keep
the law perfectly perfectly uh because of our
sinful nature then we will essentially lose our
salvation through jesus christ no that's not true
let me stop right there you know the whole thing
god does not require anything of you you cannot do
exodus 20 reading from verse 1 and god spake
all these words saying i am the law thy god
which brought thee out of the land of egypt out of
the house of bondage thou shalt have no other gods
before me you're supposed to now he'll give us the
power but we're the ones who decide no idols nor
gods before commandment two thou shalt not make
unto thee any grievan image whatever god requires
of us he makes it possible for us to do it thou
shalt not kill am i not supposed to keep that law
yes remember the sabbath day yes now here's the
problem unconverted hearts you see that's the
problem if you go to first john chapter five let's
go to first john chapter five first john five
let's read verse three and it's uh six o'clock
we're supposed to end at six so i won't go to the
whole thing this is enough for me to end on first
john chapter five reading verse 3 do we have that
for this is the love of god that we keep his
commandments how does that verse end anyone who
has it and his commandments are not grievous
that's what the bible says the word grievous
translated burdensome hard or difficult the bible
says his commandments are not grievous they're not
grievous for the one on whom the law is written
because anything written on the heart comes out
how willingly and so you tell your children stand
with all your heart you tell them put your heart
into it the bible says of christ i'd like to do
thy will o my god why yea thy law is in my heart
people find the commandments hard to keep because
the commandments are not written on their hearts
god does not require what you and i cannot do
when he says bring you all the tithe you can
do that why because the law is not grievous it
is not hard it is not burdensome for the
unconverted person or it's hell on earth
but for the true child of god obedience becomes
the highest expression of joy listen to this
statement from christ object lessons page 97
paragraph three the man who attempts to keep
the commandments of god from a sense of obligation
merely because he's required to do so will never
enter into the joy of obedience he does not obey
when the requirements of god are accounted a
burden because they cut across human inclination
we may know that the life is not a christian life
true obedience is the outworking of a principle
within it springs from the love of righteousness
the love of the law of god the essence of all
righteousness is loyalty to our redeemer this will
lead us to do right because it is right because
right doing is pleasing to god no more questions
you have to stop at six and it's six o'clock
we can go through questions questions questions
let me make a recommendation study the word
of god here is a promise from jesus christ
john 16 verse 13 how be it when he the spirit of
truth is come he will guide you into all truth
i get questions all over the world what does this
mean what can i write back have you studied it you
studied and tell me what you learned frequently i
write back have you studied it have you studied it
bible study takes work are you following me
bible study but no one wants to work and so
there's an is the fast food version
of bible study is what does that mean
yes what does that mean and i'm not judging anyone
i'm simply saying it is a trend in the church what
does this mean what does that mean i was speaking
to a group on zoom and we had a question session
and i said let's study this verse and i have
this sister reading a verse and she's looking
at the verse and reading it wrongly and i said
look at the first one and she's looking at it
and she can't see and it's right in front of her
i said look at the verse my course i wanted to
jump to the screen microscopy look at the verse
then she finally looked and looked and saw we
don't apply i was this is a general statement
you're all exceptions we don't apply ourselves
we apply ourselves when we get ready for the
sat and whatever else a ct and if you're medical
school the uh whatever and dental school and
law school sct but the bible ah yeah so they
tell me tell me tell me but tell me tell me
tell me is eating food somebody else chewed
yes there's a place for the bible teacher
on the map the preacher yes but it does not
replace you study because you must experience
what it's like when the holy spirit open your
eyes opens your eyes and you see something i tell
you you'll jump and run around the house when that
happens because god is eager to teach you make
the effort i say study get the bible get the us
the absentees commentary get ella white's books
study and say lord open thou my eyes that i may
behold wondrous things out of thy law psalm 119
verse 18 david prayed open my eyes study the word
and god will bless your life one quotation
i'm done christ object lessons page 100
paragraph one the scriptures are the great
agency in the transformation of character
jesus prayed sanctified him through thy
truth thy word is truth if studied and
obeyed the word of god works in the heart
subduing every unholy attribute is studied
and obeyed god bless you as you study his
word and walk in the light of that word
shall we close in prayer
closing prayer father and heaven we want to thank
you and praise you for this opportunity where we
could look into your word your word has said to
that we may study to show ourselves approved unto
you rightly dividing the word of truth father
give us that impression give us that desire to
study your word to know the word of god personally
and individually we thank you father for brother
randy skeet that you have lend him here and send
him here to preach your word what a blessing and
it was and father i just pray that you will
be with him for the remainder of this weekend
be with all of us father may we be closer knitted
to you and desiring to follow you and to be a
light unto this world we ask all these things
now in the precious and powerful name of jesus
amen
you